[Music]
the fight for air Travelers rights on
this Monday night
ottawa's proposed reforms aimed at
better protecting passengers it's not
your issue you shouldn't have to jump
through hoops why some critics say these
changes don't go far enough
hoping for an exit strategy we don't
know
[Music]
people can hang in there what's ottawa's
plan to help Canadians stranded in Sudan
preparing for a potential Invasion how
Taiwan is looking for lessons from
Ukraine
and the stone of schoon it's really an
iconic object an ancient symbol of
Scottish sovereignty's contentious
history
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser good
evening to you thanks for joining us as
Travelers click the book Now button on
flight websites many are hoping the
bumpy summer of 2022 won't be duplicated
but over the past year the number of air
passenger complaints to Canada's
transport regulator has more than
tripled hitting a record high tonight
the federal government is promising to
toughen up on airlines
and it will no longer be the passenger
who will have to prove that he or she is
entitled to compensation
it will now be the airline that will
need to prove that it does not have to
pay for it the transportation Minister
calls the change is significant but some
passenger rights Advocates say the
proposed rules still fall short Korea
isri has our top story tonight
Canada is trying to get back on course
after a year of travel chaos and tens of
thousands of complaints I think it's
time that we do that it's ridiculous if
it's not your issue then you shouldn't
have to jump through hoops in order to
get what you're owed the fact world
government is rewriting the
writing Bill of Rights to make get
easier to get compensation for delayed
or canceled flights this means there
will be no more loopholes where Airlines
can claim A disruption is caused by
something outside of their control
Ottawa is promising to simplify the
complaints process and reduce the burden
on customers the onus for proving
compensation is going to be in the hands
of the airline that's a very big change
from what we currently have where the
passengers are doing all the work the
government plans to toughen fines for
Airlines tenfold from twenty five
thousand dollars to two hundred and
fifty thousand but enforcement is the
big question the government agency that
handles disputes admitted last winter it
has never fined a carrier for failing to
provide compensation this is a
relatively new
um regime the changes come as the
government tries to chip away at a
backlog of 45
000 complaints I've never gotten
compensated for anything they just get
me a new flight and I missed four days
of my trip and I didn't get compensated
for it the transport Minister insists
the overhaul will change that saying
Canada is bringing in stronger rules
than the European Union considered the
gold standard the NDP transport critic
disagrees the Liberals have chosen to
double down on an approach that's
complex bureaucratic and expensive the
new Democrats want to see automatic
compensation and more clarity about
exemptions for now it seems Airlines
won't be on the hook in the event of
severe weather so this is Canada winter
is something that the Airlines and the
airports have to get used to the
government is still working out the
details around exemptions or
compensation for lost or delayed baggage
but it will likely be a while before
Canadians see money in their pockets the
changes won't come into effect until the
federal budget passes which is expected
later this spring Farah
Korea Israel Ottawa International
Airport thank you Sharia
dozens of Canadians have been airlifted
out of Sudan on board a German plain as
the ongoing violence pushes the nation
deeper into crisis I just heard earlier
today that a German plane lifted off
from Khartoum
with one German citizen on it and 58
Canadian citizens on it
we have a C-17 in the region too and we
will be airlifting as well
but there's no word on when exactly that
C-17 will be used to get more Canadians
out and for those Left Behind the
situation is growing increasingly dire
Mike trolley reports
under the cover of Darkness the Dutch
military landed in the Sudanese capital
of hartum to rescue its citizens from
the burgeoning conflict other countries
followed suit including Germany France
Spain and Italy to name a few
58 Canadians hitched a ride with Germany
but if Canada has a plan to get the rest
of its citizens to safety it's not
saying the situation in Sudan is
changing by the minute
the government is seeking assistance
from like-minded countries but for now
the 1600 Canadians registered in Sudan
are still being told no air evacuations
are possible and that you're responsible
for your own safety it really worries me
that we have Canadians who are stuck
there who've been told there is no hope
and to me it just shows a government
that really doesn't care about you know
either bolstering our military to the
point where they can respond or just
having a plan to address this
in the 10 days since fighting began
Khartoum and its residents have been
under siege gas and food are scarce
there's no access to cash and residents
are left with a choice to shelter in
place or seek a way out Sudanese
Canadian zainab Yousef and her family in
hartum have long since decided on the
latter absolute necessity desperation we
we don't know
how long people can hang in there for
the past week she's been scouring social
media for any Avenue to leave but as
quickly as one opens it closes
complicating matters or reports of
opportunists extorting thousands of
dollars for safe passage it honestly
feels like my Sudanese family and
friends and Community they're they're
left
um
defend for themselves
so for me that Exodus is is a big sign
that things are not
going to get better
it's a humanitarian crisis that could
still somehow worsen if the warring
sides don't put down their guns Mike
trolllay Global News Toronto
China's foreign minister is warning
Taiwan and its allies that they are
playing with fire if they go against
beijing's claim over the self-governing
island democracy
political tension in the region is at
its highest in decades and the Chinese
military drills simulating attacks on
Taiwan have now become routine now the
Taiwanese are preparing for an invasion
by taking lessons from Ukraine Jeff
sempel reports from Taiwan
three years ago Canadian veteran Ray
Buxton and his Taiwanese wife bought
their dream home steps from the beach on
the southern edge of Taiwan it's a nice
area it's beautifully uh beautifully
quiet most of the time especially at
night but after a couple of months that
quiet was interrupted rate like a bat
out of hell came these two fighter jets
the Taiwanese planes scrambled from a
nearby Air Base to confront a fleet of
Chinese fighter jets heading straight
for Taiwan if so part and parcel with
CCP propaganda I mean show of strength
saber rattling
provocation
foreign
so this has become something of a
routine here Chinese warplanes fly off
in the direction of Taiwan Taiwanese
fighter jets are forced to respond issue
a warning and eventually the Chinese
planes turn back to the mainland
the 80 year old lives near the air base
and says the jet engines Roar From Dawn
till Dusk her bedroom ceiling recently
collapsed from a Shockwave
the local mayor says the Chinese
flyovers have become a regular event
with the largest drills coming anytime
Taiwanese officials meet with U.S or
other Western leaders like they did this
month now every time Buxton hears the
Jets coming I wonder is this it could
this be it admittedly there have been a
couple sleep sleep semi-sleepless nights
we're worried about the future just like
many other people the Taiwanese have
lived under existential threat for 70
years and many have learned to ignore it
but beijing's recent rhetoric and
Military moves are prompting some to
prepare
this NGO is one of several recently
launched to provide survival training
for civilians from first aid to search
and rescue organizers overwhelmed by the
demand especially after Russia invaded
Ukraine I think it drove home the the
message that our world can get turned
upside down just like that right at the
whim of an autocrat well Ukraine
thwarted Russia's full-scale Invasion
recently leaked U.S intelligence
suggests Taiwan is highly vulnerable to
a Chinese Air Attack with barely half
its aircraft said to be fully Mission
capable
thank you thank you for seeing us we put
concerns about taiwan's military
Readiness to its Minister of Foreign
Affairs is Taiwan prepared for the
prospect of a Chinese this is a very
good question that the Taiwanese people
are more determined than ever in
defending ourselves his government is
extending mandatory military free
service from four months up to a year
while ramping up defense spending a
Ukrainian flag hangs in his office for
inspiration the ukrainians are able to
withstand the onslaught of one of the
largest military in the world
and that tells us that determination and
strategy might matter we are learning
from the biblical prophecy of David
versus Goliath
and I want to say that Taiwan will
prevail and democracy will prevail
there's a lot of catching up that needs
to be done this Canadian Security
analyst has lived in Taiwan for two
decades after years of Taiwanese
complacency he says beijing's
belligerence is a wake-up call Beijing I
would argue shot itself in the foot with
its major drills it again makes it the
threat all the more apparent to the
Taiwanese since they are adamant that
they want to defend their way of life
they are willing to do what is necessary
a recent poll found the vast majority of
Taiwanese would fight to defend their
democracy the lesson from Ukraine if a
powerful neighbor invades don't count
out the underdog Jeff Semple Global News
Taipei
Taiwan has been targeted by the Chinese
government's disinformation and meddling
for years tomorrow how Taiwan is
fighting back against interference
campaigns and what Canada could learn
from their experience
new federal research suggests that this
country may be seriously underestimating
its oil sector's impact on our climate
this is according to a new study by
environment and climate change Canada
Alberta's oil sands are releasing far
more carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
than what's been reported Heather urac's
West explains how that could be putting
Canada's own climate goals at risk
it's an industry that drives the
Canadian economy but the oil and gas
sector produces much of the country's
greenhouse gas emissions as well it's
about a quarter of our emissions are
associated with the production and you
know kind of processing of oil and gas
before it turns into end use products
right now oil sounds emissions are
measured using engineering estimates
looking at how much fuel is being
combusted on the ground but a new
federal study measured emissions using
samples collected from the air above the
Athabasca oil sands in 2018. the air
samples measured over 30 megatons more
CO2 than what had been otherwise
reported 30 megatons is on the order of
a small European country like
Switzerland their entire annual
emissions for a year so so it's quite
big or as another perspective it would
be about six percent of Canada's total
greenhouse gases the oil industry says
while it welcomes new research it does
have concerns about this particular
study for one it says emission rates
were determined from a limited number of
flights with short intervals of sampling
time and did not take into consideration
days when facilities were not in
operation Canada's environment Minister
says he's yet to review the results of
the report but the study adds to a
growing body of evidence suggesting
Canada's level of greenhouse gas
emissions is not fully understood it's
worrisome if we keep finding additional
emissions above and beyond what we
originally had identified because it
means that there is more work for us to
to do because no matter the starting
point the deadline to reach the
country's Net Zero Target is just over
two decades away Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
the demands to make a deal coming up how
talks are going between Ottawa and
striking government workers
there is no end in sight to a public
service strike disrupting important
Services across our country more than
155 thousand federal workers are on
their sixth day of job action demanding
better pay and more flexibility and now
they're moving pick a lines to more
strategic locations our chief political
correspondent David Aiken joins us from
Ottawa with where things stand David
well far on both sides we're at the
negotiating table today even as the
union tried to ramp up efforts to get a
deal
the public service Alliance of Canada
set up picket lines at some of Canada's
ports including the country's busiest
port in Vancouver we're out here today
because Public Service Alliance of
Canada members are escalating strike
actions from coast to coast to coast
striking workers also picketed outside
the East Coast headquarters of Canada's
Navy
and they tried to disrupt operations at
the Port of Montreal all I can say is
please be patient please support us uh
that's how we're going to get to an end
Montreal's Port Authority said the
impact on operations there was minimal
new picket lines were also set up
outside some RCMP stations in Alberta
and Newfoundland at Coast Guard stations
in BC and Ontario and at federal
penitentiaries in Ontario
[Music]
in the House of Commons New Democrats
took up the cause of striking workers
workers deserve to be treated with
respect but Canada's Public Service
workers have been without a contract for
two years
the government says the union came to
the table with
570 demands and all but a handful have
now been resolved
has been working around the clock to
negotiate new Collective agreements that
are fair
man
still wages and work from home rules are
the key issues Farah
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you David
[Music]
seismic shake-ups ahead two major honor
Personalities in the U.S make abrupt
exits
and we'll be back on Monday in the
meantime have the best weekend
while it's certainly not the Monday
Tucker Carlson was expecting that ended
up being his final broadcast on Fox News
the controversial right wing TV host is
out in a statement the network says both
parties agreed to part ways immediately
ending his highly rated show Tucker
Carlson tonight The Primetime host was
known for pushing baseless conspiracies
including lies that the 2020 election
was stolen from former president Donald
Trump Carlson's exit comes after Fox
settled a multi-million dollar
defamation suit with Dominion voting
systems over the Network's dissemination
of misinformation
and a similar shake up at CNN the news
giant fired long-time anchor Don Lemon
lemon face criticism in February for
Honor remarks about women and aging but
he's made many concerning comments over
his 17 years with CNN
a Kentucky police officer who fired the
Fatal shot that killed Brianna Taylor
has a new job in law enforcement
demonstrators gathered at the Carroll
County Courthouse this morning to
protest the hire miles Cosgrove started
working for its Sheriff's Department
last week he was fired from the
Louisville Metro Police Department in
2021 for violating use of force
procedures and failing to use a body
camera during the raid on Taylor's
apartment Brianna Taylor was killed in
March of 2020 by police executing a no
knock search warrant
[Music]
the coronation Stone next the story of a
legendary symbol crucial to the crowning
of King Charles
[Music]
we're less than two weeks away from the
coronation of King Charles III and that
stone of schoon will sit under the
coronation chair but as Crystal
gomancing explains the precious object
has a storied past
the stone of schoon named after the
medieval village in perthshire where
it's believed to have originated and
where in ancient times Scottish Kings
were crowned it's really an iconic
object archaeologist Rachel Pickering
calls it a symbol of statehood with the
coronation of King Charles III the stone
of schoon is having a Renaissance
essentially strict from the Scottish
King and taken to England sort of as War
booty as a trophy of Edward the First's
victory over at Scotland War booty from
1296 King Edward the first had the
precious stone also referred to as the
stone of Destiny incorporated into a new
Throne at Westminster Abbey starting its
use in coronations in England but in
1950 there was a robbery
it was during the early hours of
Christmas this morning at the historic
Stone of scorn was removed from the
coronation chair in Westminster Abbey
somehow four Glasgow University students
broke in and stole it I have no idea how
they managed it and such a great big
heavy object and they apparently dragged
it on a coat along the tiles through
Westminster Abbey four months later it
showed up at the arborth Abbey in
Scotland but it wasn't until 1996 that
the UK government and Queen Elizabeth II
agreed it should remain in the North
when the stone of schoon was officially
returned to Scotland 10 000 people lined
up here along the Royal Mile and watched
it make its way back to Edinburgh Castle
where it has lived ever since under lock
and key
Legend has it the stone was used by the
biblical figure Jacob it possibly
traveled to Egypt Spain and later
Ireland but historic environment
Scotland is confident of its local
Origins since its return to Scotland
experts have been testing and analyzing
the stone high resolution imaging
recently revealed something resembling
Roman numerals etched into the Sandstone
leading to a new area of research I hope
that now we have an opportunity to
celebrate the object and to emphasize
just how interesting and important this
is a rock solid link to past present and
future
Crystal gomancing Global News Edinburgh
Scotland
and Global News will have special
coverage of the king's coronation on May
6th Donna Friesen will be live in London
at 5 a.m Eastern 2 A.M Pacific right
here on global and that's global
national for this Monday night I'm Farah
Nasser and on behalf of our whole crew I
want to thank you so much for spending
part of your Monday evening with us
tonight's your Canada is Long Lake in
Yellowknife Chris gayles will be on the
anchor desk tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
foreign
[Music]